♫ I never thought, my life could be ♫
OH MY GOD
♫ Because I've got a golden ticket ♫
Oh my God
♫ I've got a golden twinkle in my eye ♫
Today I am so excited
♫ I've got a golden ticket ♫
Uh.. Nintendo has given me this unique opportunity
Uh to play the new Zelda game
I got this tweet from Shigeru Miyamoto
"Yo PewDiePie love your bomb ass video,
almost as much as I love cocaine and women"
"here's the latest build of the Zelda game I hope you like it"
You guys know me
I am the biggest Legend of Zelda fan, EVER!
like if you watch other Zelda fans on YouTube, Fuck 'em
so im so excited to play the NEW Legend of Zelda game
I've been waiting for this
Oh My God, it looks
here we go, oh my god
it's a, it's a, it's a Zelda game coz it's trade marked
*low quality music plays*
really good choice of menu music
*MUSIC INTENSIFIES*
o o o ooooo oohhh
*girl* But father what it something happens to you
*dad* I will take the triforce of courage to protect me
*dad* if you don't hear from me in a month, send Link
*PewDiePie* Laughs
*Link* oh boy I'm so ...
*pewdiepie* Oh My God, Link, is he wearing lipstick
is that a butt hole
that's Links butt hole
*narrator* first move the triforce to pick a place on the map
what the ...
*narrator* then press button 1
I'll fly there in a flash
shh, well she, oh Zelda can fly now!?
this is the real Ninten-
*narrator* move the controller to move me left or right
Great
*narrator* up and over makes me leap
where's the button to kill yourself
*narrator* luckily i brought my smart sword
it won't hurt anyone friendly
*pewdiepie* smart sword what is this an iPhone, what the fuck
*old man* course I'm on your side
WOW
*old man* but I still have to sell the stuff
alright now we know how to play
Oh God
*more low quality music plays*
the music
I love it
It's the best
err lets do, what's the difference between start game and new game
ok
new game please
ok, ahh how about we go to Aru Ainu
Hey we are in Africa *laughs*
What happened?
they really stuffed up the graphics on the Nintendo Switch
OH MY GOD its...
The lion king character, What ever
The resolution is incredible, the frame rate is so smooth
This is unlike any gaming experience
I have ever experienced
And you know I always give you honest reviews
Like what I..
If I don't like something, I'll tell, I'll be sure to tell you guys
I'll be the first one to say it
ahh, also full disclosure this is a sponsored video by Nintendo
they are paying for this review, A lot-a lot of money
When I asked them to send me a switch
They did not just
Not reply at all
and tell me to fuck off-
What the fuck happened there
My left ear is uh - really enjoying..
This.
This is great
It's a bit- Oh, oh shit!
Oh my god
It didn't die.
Great
I always love how Nintendo always innovates-, comes up with new
Y'know they don't put graphics first, it's not about the graphics (obvious sarcasm)
It's about the gameplay
It's always been about the gameplay
*low quality sword swing noise*
Let's run away from these- oh ok
Now we can go here?
Excellent.
Hey(a), it's granna.
Granny
I killed her.
Wow, that was fun.
*dying hyena*
*more LQ sword slashing*
what's happening
Woman: "Hello Deary, oh just a minute."
*woman speaks russian or some shit i dont speak cyka blyat*
I love her smile
*Laughs* She's so happy about the blanket
*LQ sword slashing*
Woah
I can shoot blankets now thanks to Granny!
She gave me the blanket sword
I shoot blankets now through my sword
I love Legend of Zelda it's my favourite game
Okay we are done here
We are done here we have the blanket sword
Now, we can go to Tokyo Tower
No, actually we're gonna go to uh
uh. Sakado
Shoot the blankets
Block it
Bring it, dinosaur rat
Shoot the blanket
Fuck.
You're not gonna get me this time
Fucking dinosaurs
Why am I not shooting blankets
There it is!
Excellent.
Having a lot of fun.
Hey, it's Christopher Lloyd!
Thanks for sharing, Christopher
Woman: "Sorry, Zelda."
*cash cash get bitches money sound effect*
"Not enough rupees."
What is with the fucking character movements
It's like
*dick up ass*
OF COUUURRRRSEEE *laughs*
"You'll have to wipe out a few more enemies to get that."
Ok, now we got the rope, we got the lantern
Let's get out of here
Oh man, you just have to appreciate the vastness of the universe in the Legend of Zelda
uhhh gameplay
its uh
it - it inspires me
it really does, it really does inspire me-
Let's go to kobitan
How is this guy doin'
Wha-
You're just going to ignore me like that?
Come back here boi
Where's he going
Oh!
Fuck
Take blankets!
Fuck, okay
This is bad
Aight let's go in here
Honestly I think this might be one of the best Zeldas out there
Everyone keeps talking about the Ocarina of Time like it's
a classic, it's never gonna get better
I don't wanna say it too soon, y'know
I've only been playing for a few minutes but I really do think
Shit
I think this one has potential
I think we have a new champion, is what I'm saying
What the fuck, where-
Fucking demon from hell
Okay
Ooh! Hey
I didn't realise how thick Zelda was
Doin' pretty well here.
Zelda looks like she ate something really bad
I gotta say, I really like her
the art direction they went with
Cool so now we can go in here and uh
Talk to this- Hey, how ya doin'?
"Those darn enemies have eaten everything"
"I'd give anything for a steak!"
Pixar
Pixar needs to hire the animators
this is the new generation of animation
look at their faces, their expressions
Hey, Is That The Swedish Flag?
Finally! Hey Shigeru Miyamoto, you crazy bastard,
You put that little reference in there for me
Thank you
Thank you so much
That's very kind of you
Great, I guess now we go to Abitaru
The fucking desert
When do I play as Link? I-
I don't, I don't know
Link is busy
Fucking
There we go
Great, fuckin' mosquitoes
Great. *exhaling pure depression*
It feels so good to play a Legend of Zelda game again
It really reminds me of why I love video games
and why
*autistic moment*
Nintendo always seizes to amaze me with
their innovation
Some would criticise them and say they're trying too hard
to innovate and
I, I say, uhh
I say they are haters
Disgusting haters.
And they don't understand
Zelda like I do
No one understands Zelda
Let's go in here that seems great
HOLYSHIT it's a crab
Great
Glad we did that
Can the crab be killed?
Yes it can
Excellent.
We killed the crab everyone. I repeat,
The crab is dead
*swedish man laughs*
No
Oh shit I can walk up here
Oh for fuck's sake
*releases nut, yelling*
Please
Make this jump
Okay, make this jump
For fuck's sake
Fuck off
They keep comin'
Jump
It's impossible
The jump is impossible
I can definitely see myself sinking 6,000 hours into this game
I really wanna max out all the characters,
Do all the sidequests,
and of course, pay for the hard mode later on
the DLC
I really look forward
to pay for something that should just be free
YES!
HELLYE
Woman: "Nice job over the pit!"
"Here, have a drink!"
Zelda: "Thanks."
Yeah, I jumped over that fucking shit
"Thanks!"
JESUS
Now if my theory is correct, we need to blow up this bomb
I mean, rock
How do we do that
Excellent
Now, go
Great, we have one more chance
It didn't do anything
It didn't do anythign *sobs in swedish*
Man: "Have mercy!"
King: "After you've scrubbed all the floors in Hyrule, then we can talk about mercy"
So, when you beat the game
You kinda wonder, what happened to Link
Link: "What happened?"
*swedish man's last breath (colourised, 1940)*
*distorted yelling* What happened?
*Laughing*
Jesus Christ
You know, this may be a biased review because
I am such a huge Legend of Zelda fan
This is it
Go out and buy
The Nintendo switch right now
It's gonna change gaming forever
It is incredible
It is breathtaking
Now excuse me, I have to leave because I wanna die
I wanna die a horrible death
It's the only cure for what I've just witnessed
So I'll see you in uh
Never
But here's another video anyway
and just check that out if you like that
Thanks again to Nintendo for letting me play the game
Really appreciate it, thank you so much
Love you guys so much
and uh
heil